Hello Dr. Kevin Connors here at a presentation about modified citrus pectin one of my favorite supplements
So I call this nature's key later key later is just a Latin word that means to grab on to and that's what modified citrus pectin does
It's a very mild key later in your body. I believe that I
separate
different
So there's different nutraceutical keylators that you can take ETA, DMSA, or two strong or keylators that I call them systemic keylators
And then I call modified citrus pectin. I label that as a local key later
Meaning that it doesn't pull mercury out of a fillet
That's in your tooth, but it'll help keylite things out of your blood and out of your tissue pretty well
Especially out of the blood. So modified citrus pectin is one of those great local or mild keylators
That just can't suggest to anybody even if they have they still have
Mercury fillets. So if a person that has mercury fillets, you cannot use ETA or DMSO
DMSA as a key later it will pull that right out of their teeth into the blood and it'll make them sicker than they were before
So if you're listening to this and you still have silver fillets and
You are using a product with ETA or DMSA in it you have to stop that right away. Do not use those harsh
They're not harsh but the strong keylators. You can't use those if you have any mercury fillets
If you have even metal implants
Usually stainless steel and titanium implants will be fine
But if you have any nickel implants, you cannot use those keylators. You can however you as modified citrus pectin
That's what we're going to talk about
Modified citrus pectin is a great
Glected three blocker. Glected three is a
Is a chemical in our body that does a lot of things. It helps heal wounds. So it's important
Whatever we're talking about natural chemicals in our body. We don't want to say that they're good or bad
They're all good
It's just that glected three can become can become over expressed in your body
You could have high levels of it and if you have high levels of glected three
It could be a major problem with cancer with a chronic inflammatory state with heart disease and with strokes
Glected three is also upregulated in pulmonary liver and real fibrosis because it really is a
Fibrotic precursor it helps increase
Healing helps increase scar tissue while you think scar tissue is bad while scar tissue is important when you need to heal a wound
So we just don't want to have too high of levels
Typically glected three levels are not ever too high in children
But they can be too high in adults
So that's what we're really looking at you can measure them
There are blood tests that you can measure glected three
But I think after this study you're just going to say well forget that
I don't need to go to that expense. I'd rather just spend it unbiased and modified
Citrus-packed and taking it because it's going to be so good for me
So what glected three dozen cancer increases the cells ability to bind together
And it makes it more difficult for your immune system to kill those cells
So remember everybody has cancer cells in their body
It's when they start replicating and have the ability to exceed your immune systems ability to kill them
Is that when we end up with a diagnosis of cancer so
High levels of glected three in your body
Cause cancer to have a better better ability to elude your immune systems ability to kill it because
As cancer grows in
Clubs together you could say different cancer cells then your immune system has a much more difficult time to kill the cancer
glected three over
X is overexpressed
And
And it's why it's bad for overexpression of glected three and cancer patients also decreases
Apoptosis so apoptosis is normal programmed cell death so
Normally a cell lives a certain time
Typically about six to twelve weeks and then it reproduces another cell and then that mother cell will die
That's called apoptosis
What cancer is is that for some reason that mother cell didn't die
Well high levels of glected three can
Decrease your apoptotic ability
It also decrease apoptosis when a cancer has already started so when the cancer has already started
And it's a cell hasn't died and it's stuck in a rapid replication phase
That's what cancer is
It's it's you want to try to kill that cancer. So it's more difficult to
Create an apoptotic reaction when a person has high levels of glected three
It increases circulated tumor cell adhesion
so
When a person has cancer
Cell didn't die
And the cell is in a rapid replication phase and it's rapidly replicated cells that also are not going through apoptosis
In a rapidly replicating so the cell has become in this giant mass of cells now and
Blog before the person has ever got a diagnosis of cancer because it's still not big enough to palpate or to see on an MRI or CT scan
It is breaking off cells called circulating tumor cells
Now circulating tumor cells are not yet technically cancer because they're not in a rapid replication phase
So they are circulating through your body
Looking for a place to set up home and raise a family you could say
Those circulated tumor cells if there's high levels of glected three of that person's body have a better chance of
Eluting the immune system adhering to some cell
wall and start to replicate and become cancer
So
Having high levels of glected three increases the chance of circulated tumor health
Subtumor cells adhesion to a wall. It's it's setting up home and raising a family
Also, it increases cell growth and differentiation. That's what you do not with cancer
It's circa glected three is it immune to suppress it in itself and it increases angiogenesis that means
Growth of blood vessels into a cancer
It also increases metastasis
So it's obviously all around bad guy for a person with cancer
Matter of fact you could measure
Glected three and you could actually give a person a risk level
So they're at a high risk when the measurement of glected three in their blood test exceeds 17.8 nanograms per milliliter
Um, now again, I typically never measure glected three levels because we just go ahead and treat it anyhow
so um
We'll skip that piece right there
What happens with modified citrus pectin?
Modified citrus pectin first of all modified citrus pectin is a way to modify the enzyme in the citrus pectin
So it's more easily absorbed into your body and it can do its work in the bloodstream in the extracellular spaces
Modified citrus pectin breaks collected three's body capacity to
tumour cells so
Should all cancer patients be on modified citrus pectin?
Well, yes and no, it's a good it's a great approach. There really is zero side effects of modified citrus pectin
So everybody can be on it. I put little kids on modified citrus pectin
It dissolves wonderfully in a little bit of orange juice or a little bit of citrus juice
And you just drink it down and it's really completely tasteless
So it's really easy to take. It's relatively inexpensive for what you get out of the supplement
So it's a great addition to any sort of supplement package
It also modified citrus pectin basically
Bonds to the glected three and it will inactivate the glected three because a glected three what it does is it acts as a
Increase
Fibrogenic organisms. So it increases the adhesive capability of
Cells that's the whole purpose of it is that you would
Scar tissue to form well you do not want
Glected excess neglected three causing
Adhesive increase adhesive molecule so that
Heavy metals and toxins will more readily adhesive on the vessel walls
And cause an immune reaction and cause a blockage in a vessel
You don't want to
Have this adhesive cancer cells together like we said already
So modified citrus pectin actually binds to those adhesion parts of the glected three molecule
So it doesn't have its adhesive property
And again what we said it's nature's key later for circulated tumor cells
So it grabs circulated tumor cells and helps pull circulated tumor cells out of your body
So it's any aggressive cancer
Definitely want to go on a modified citrus pectin product
It's also a great heavy metal key later
So if a person is dealing with they're not dealing with cancer
But they're dealing with some sort of heart disease or they're dealing with
Just a node heavy metal toxicity
It is a great
Natural key later that is not aggressive or you could say a mild key later
Hard to read that article they put on there
But it talks about lead levels with children and what you could what could you do with children with lead levels
Because when you use like this other little piece that I have supplemental facts there
DMSA and EDTA are very
Strong key later so you have to be careful using that because it'll do a lot of pulling
Out of the tissue which is great
So a key later is a substance that will grab onto things
So you wasn't is that a good thing we want to use a strong key later
Well, you have to be careful because it drops a lot too
So you could have secondary detox reactions
When you use a heavy key later
And it's not typically recommended with children to use those heavy key letters
And again like I said before you can't use it if you have any metal in your body
So modified citrus pectin cilantro clorella things like that are things that have to be used
As a mild key later
So what kind of dosage do we use with this product? Well
Anywhere between one and a half to ten grams
Is a typical dosage two products that I had and then I'll show you
What is a high dose product or what is a low dose product it really depends on what you're trying to do
So if the person has no cardiovascular disease you want to take it least or no cancer
You want to take at least five grams of modified citrus pectin a day
If you're trying to do a keylation for a heavy metal toxicity
That I suggest a lower dose and mix it with some other things
So as an example this product by echo new genetics is pectusol C
It's a great solely a modified citrus pectin product
And each scoop is five grams
So if you want to take ten to fifteen grams
If you have cancer or heart disease it's easy to get that in by just simply dissolving it in some juice
This other product by designs for health called metal exicidurgy is a lower dose
It's it's 1.5 grams of modified citrus pectin
But it has cilantro and a bunch of other mild keylators in some other synergistic things for it's more specifically for use as a
as a general holistic
mild keylator in the person's body great products both of them so I personally take both of these products
So I take pectusol C just because of the history of of cancer and history of heart disease in my family
And then I have mercury toxicity so I do take the metal ex as well
So good products a good thing to add to your protocol. There's zero side effects. It's a great for so many things in your body